bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors un procès
inéquitable injuste pas transparent une
parodie même une farce
neil verdict ni le procès n'ont
satisfait les eaux élevé est ce que vous
comprenez oui et non parce que quelque
part le procès a été effectuée sous une
supervision des cinq pays le permanent
de puissance permanente de l'onu est en
fait l'arabie saoudite cherchait avant
tout disons que de se débarrasser dans
le fardeau qui était qui ternit l'image
de l'arabie saudite comme vous l'avez
mentionné dans le cadre de votre
reportage est en fait terni l'image de
l'arabie saoudite dans le monde et
empêché en même temps l'ensemble des
objectifs et des réformes économiques
dans le cadre de la vision 2030
ceci en fait a pu profiter à certains
rivaux de l'arabie saoudite rivaux
régionaux de l'arabie saudite et de
l'utiliser dans le cadre d'un marketing
ou dans le cadre de deux opérations de
com il ne faut pas oublier aussi que le
fait de réviser le procès le jugement
qui est passé donc d'une condamnation à
mort à des peines de prison
c est intervenu suite aux pardons
accordés par les fils de la victime
elle-même vis-à-vis de ces de ses
assassins
techniquement il s'agit d'une barre d'un
fonctionnement normal de la justice
saoudienne et des conséquences qui ont
été donc donner suite à ce pardon d'une
part et dans notre bar jeu j'aurais vu
en fait j'aurais vu les mêmes acteurs
qui avait critiqué l'arabie saoudite
d'avoir réviser le jugement les avoir
critiqués 6 et 6 et même assassin aurait
été condamné à mort donc en même temps
c'était c'était une affaire de cul collé
rivaux régionaux utilisé en matière de
com à usage politique et à des sujets
entre guillemets personnel pour de
règlements de compte notamment sur le
patronat depuis l'art du flan sunnites
de la région
alors vous parlez des rivaux régionaux
mais en tout cas en ce moment qui
critiquent en tout cas ce verdict final
et ce procès c'est surtout les ong plus
que les rivaux régionaux
vous dites également que ce meurtre a
beaucoup terni l'image de l'arabie
saoudite mais clairement dont l'effet
est ce que vous voyez vraiment un
changement est ce que ce meurtre à
faisait à freiner a ralenti les
partenariats les collaborations que le
royaume saoudien a avec le reste du
monde dans l'est c'est exactement ce
vous avez mentionné totalement véridique
dans le sens où on se souvient du fameux
fameux sommet du caveau du désert ou
incertains où les organisateurs
notamment un certain richard attias a dû
entre guillemets fait appel à ses
contacts personnels dans le but est
d'essayer de compenser la réussite ça
c'est indéniable parce que l'image de
l'arabie saoudite a été là était tachée
par cet événement dont on peut nous dire
oui ou non il ya des coupables ou dont
les commanditaires ont effectué donc
cette action avec le film la
connaissance ou pas des hauts dirigeants
après je pense que c'était un fardeau en
termes de pommes qui devait s'en
débarrasser la sphère dure depuis à peu
près deux ans et pour aller en lavant et
pour essayer de reprendre le train le
chemin des réformes économiques dans le
cadre de la vision 2030 surtout dans le
cadre d'une guigne veut dire une crise
entre guillemets une crise économique où
le prix du baril du pétrole affecte
l'ensemble des économies des pays de la
région
il s'avère nécessaire de ce débat dans
l'île mais de mettre à côté de fermer
certains dossiers qui pose qui était
intense en quelque sorte des chars dit
qu'il fallait s'en débarrasser
alors ce qu'on voulait savoir en tout
cas ce que les ong
en tout cas la femme deux âmes à leurs
taches rouges ils voulaient savoir
c'était faire la lumière sur ce qui
s'est réellement passé le 2 octobre 2018
et qui a commandité ce meurtre en
turquie est ce que ce procès a vraiment
permis d'identifier les véritables
responsables de cette affaire alors la
nature discrète et confidentielles de ce
procès a rendu disons non identifiable
pour le commun une personne lambda que
les puissants des cinq puissances
permanente de l'onu qui supervise il
ensemble du processus judiciaire sont
satisfaits de ce procès ce
indépendamment
si la fin de monsieur khashoggi a pu
avoir connaissance des circonstances de
son décès alors quelle est la marge de
manoeuvre de la turquie dans cette
affaire parce que on le rappelle le
journaliste a bien été tuée à istanbul
et on sait que la turquie a jugé des
responsables par coutumace et elle a
vraiment une marge variable dans cette
histoire la seule marge de manoeuvre
pour la turquie dans un premier temps
c'est un terme de tom parce que
n'oublions pas que les services secrets
turcs eux le mythe n a pas arrêté de
fuite et à travers des de la presse
locale certains événements citant comme
quoi donc l'ambassade saoudienne en
turquie était sous écoute et elle a été
exploitée à plusieurs reprises mis à
part les plantes comme je ne pense pas
que la turquie à adam son intérêt
d'augmenter de provoquer des escalades
avec le rival saoudien si on voit très
bien que même l'arabie saoudite n'a pas
augmenté n'a pas escalader ses propos
vis-à-vis de la turquie notamment calmer
les tensions
donc je ne pense pas que la manoeuvre
tube aller au delà de certains manoeuvre
de com qui ont déjà été utilisés et a
donc à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on va on va
vers une sorte de stabilisation vers ce
dossier l'a vu qu'il a acquis là qu'il a
pris fin on en revient surtout vers le
fait que les enfants de la veuve de la
victime ont pu intrigues ont pu accorder
leur pardon des assassins et se fait le
fait d'avoir accordé ce barcamp est la
cause principale de ne pas avoir
condamné ces autres personnes une
condamnation à mort simplement hassan
ahmad yade merci d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france je rappelle
que vous êtes fondateur de ds consulter